America Next that's the focus of
tonight's
angle all right today finally Joe Biden
emerged 90 minutes late to speak about
well the evil attacks by Hamas against
the Israeli people now although he was
unequivocal about America's support for
Israel and the depravity of these
incursions there was no mention of
Iran's role in the planning and the
funding of these attacks nor did he
announce any reconsideration of the $6
billion payment to Iran for that
prisoner swap mostly it was generalities
this is a moment for the United States
to come together to grieve with those
who are
mourning let's be real
clear there is no place for hate in
America okay well if he's really against
hate then he should call a prosecutorial
ceasefire against his political
adversaries like the former president
and direct his doj and DHS to stop
making conservative Americans feel like
they're the enemy or like they're the
violent extremists out there now we are
seeing a lot of hate lately anti-semitic
hate at Pro Palestinian protests on the
streets of Manhattan thank you all for
being here for raising your voices to
celebrate the Glorious victory of the
resistance it is right to Rebel it is
right to Rebel Israel go to H Israel go
to now this is a good time I think to
remind everyone that before
9911 we didn't give a lot of thought
about who we were allowing into America
nor did we give a lot of thought to how
we track people to make sure that even
if they got a Visa they left when they
were supposed to and that they were here
for the right reasons remember all those
terrorists arrived on tourist visas
business visas and one on a student visa
but now 22 years after September 11th
would be terrorists don't need to bother
with a lengthy Visa process or
background checks they can walk right
across the Rio Grand on a Friday night
last month the administration reported
that the border patrol had stopped 160
individuals on the terror watch list at
the southern border and that number by
the way is rising and beyond that
they're the so-called special interest
aliens now these are individuals mostly
from Middle Eastern countries known to
Harbor terrorists and during the past
two years I fell over when I saw these
numbers the people apprehended that the
special interest aliens the number is
staggering early last month Senator
Langford pressed ice specifically about
this class of migrants the special
interest aliens we're trying to figure
out the it Tales of them and as far as
we can tell they're being processed and
released in the country awaiting a
hearing in the future and we don't have
a day-to-day supervision of those
individuals is that accurate or not
accurate Mr Bible it it's accurate that
we're we're not tracking them on a
day-to-day basis not not the totality of
himself like weding himself change that
depends not the totality of them what
weasle words which is what we've heard
from the White House National Security
adviser Jake Sullivan he heard that
today now I guess he thought he was
reassuring Americans who are anxious
about a possible attack here the focus
that we have right now on protecting
Americans here at home against anyone
who would seek to exploit or piggy back
on what is unfolded ensuring that any
terrorist threat here in the United
States or to the United States or to
Americans uh anywhere in the world that
we are at a heighten state of vigilance
to deal with that wait a second a
heighten state of vigilance really now
do scenes like this scream vigilance and
a sense of seriousness about the
potential threats we're facing of the
what 8 million or so who've been waved
into the country that we know about how
many of those individ idual in that line
that you're watching right there how
many have been vetted and what does that
vetting look like when migrants have no
real papers now it is terrifying to
think how many potential terrorists
border patrol has already missed look
with tens of thousands of people
crossing every week Lord Only Knows not
their fault they don't have enough
people things at the border are so bad
that the media this is reflexive right
reflexive move on their part are
accusing the GOP of pouncing and seizing
upon the issue sweetheart I've been on
this issue for 25 years and high-profile
Democrats in Denver San Diego New York
Chicago they're even demanding action
now most of the liberal Mayors and
governors We we played the sound bites
on this angle most of them are upset
about the influx causing a lack of
funding and the overcrowding they're not
really worrying about the future Terror
attacks that could occur but they should
be but look Democrats they're far more
engaged in demonizing the Maga crowd
than stopping a catastrophe in their own
backyard let there be no question Donald
Trump and his magga Republicans are
determined to spread anger hate and
division but the extreme magga
Republicans are focused on trying to
drive their conspiracy
theories and their right-wing ideology
and magga extremism is disastrous for
the country now last week in Newsweek we
learned that the FBI is allegedly
targeting Trump followers in the leadup
to the election again the Biden focus is
now and always will be prosecuting and
harassing their political opponents not
preventing the actual terrorists or the
transnational gang threats that are
being uh you know foisted upon us
they're Brewing all around us certainly
in the southern border coming up so what
better way for a terror Network right
now to disperse and then disappear into
the general population than amidst
hordes of Venezuelans and Hondurans and
others some of them criminals others
looking for a better life we don't
really know it's a perfect cover and no
visa application or fees
necessary as Israel locks down its own
border with Gaza and as we spend
billions helping Ukraine lock down
theirs Biden at our border refuses to
pull up his bidos map anyone can exploit
it now how in the world does this make
any sense unless it's
purposeful the Stark truth tonight is
this if we do not change course
politically and policy-wise
yes we could be next and that's the
angle hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else